sorry I'm just trying to wrap my head  around  um around that so what are the hours  regular hours  you do realize  this is a very competitive position yeah  sure I understand that what I don't  understand is how you feel so  comfortable asking someone to work  without pay  you know when I was your age they told  me all I could be was the secretary okay  but secretaries get paid that's not the  point well when you were my age did you  have sixty thousand dollars of debt how  about this when I was your age I was the  only woman in a room full of men but you  had a job okay you know you're getting  paid am I wrong time for this clearly  you're a bit spoiled spoiled let me be  frank with you you don't belong here  because you think everyone is out to get  you none of us are out to get you  especially me I'm trying to help this  was a fantastic Liz thanks very much  thank you no more talking just leave  thank you so much you want to tell me  what to do put me on the payroll how  about that